all right so let's shift to the
environment if you listen to the news
it's getting hotter everybody's freaking
out about everything we don't have clean
water all of these things calm me down
well I don't want to get into a debate
on into the debate over all the signs of
global warming I'll leave it to the
specialists certainly I do acknowledge
that there is a consensus that the world
is warming whether it is warming at a
too high rate or a luke warming rate and
where it's heading
obviously prediction of the future is
that's the most difficult thing I'm
going to leave that to specialists into
scientists yeah just very quickly on
that though is it possible that in some
of the places that it's warming it's
actually good that it's warming well
suddenly this this this one scientists
from Holland called professor tall has
calculated the likely costs and benefits
of global warming until 2018 or so and
he thought that because of the growing
bigger because of the longer growing
season we'll be able to actually bring
in more more and more food grow more
food he also thought that there's also
some evidence
the world is greening as a result of
more co2 in the atmosphere but I do
acknowledge I want to make it very clear
any hate mail to you or to me I'm going
to get hate mail either way
knowledge away I want to acknowledge
that there are serious concerns and and
I'm I'm basically a guy who is a Tecna
optimist I want to look for solutions to
these problems rather than what I don't
want to do is to stop economic
development I don't want to stop
economic development in developing
countries because it's extremely
important
that's that people who are very very
poor should not be very very poor it's
very important that if a woman in Angola
or in Zambia has a premature birth she
should be able to have an access to a to
an incubator that is run on a on a on an
electricity grid that is not going to
collapse for example okay that that
people care can air-conditioned their
homes let's say in Africa or they can
they can keep themselves warm in in
Argentina basically that that is my my
goal not to stop economic development
that is particularly if true of of poor
countries but I also think that it
applies to rich countries if if we can
make life more comfortable for people I
I see no III think it would be very
difficult especially within the
Democratic contact context to stop that
now look at what's happening in in
macrons Paris we've seen riots yeah way
that that country has and hasn't seen
since the 1960s why is that that's
because the environmental concerns of
the French elite macron included are
bumping against the living standards and
limitations on the living standards of
ordinary French men and women if you
increase the price of electricity
dramatically in order to make people cut
down on electricity it's also going to
reduce their both their comfort but also
the standard of living you're going to
put additional taxes on this that and
the other cars gasoline what have you
eventually people are going
upset and are going to start voting for
some very unpleasant people mm-hmm and
this is something that we see happening
throughout Europe now there are many
different reasons why people vote for
for unpleasant political parties but a
fundamental feeling that that standards
of living in Europe are stagnating and
that they are being taxed to a point
where they actually have to go out and
protest in the streets burn hundreds of
cars man basically vandalize the Arc de
Triomphe yeah so these things are
happening so what I want to do is to
sort of navigate a middle course between
between concerns of the environment and
and and continued economic development
and continued prosperity and I think
that the answer could potentially be
found in techno Upton ISM as I would
call it so I would consider fracking to
be a good example of Technol optimism
okay
burning of one unit of natural gas
produces half as much co2 emissions as
burning of coal so I think it would make
a lot of sense to burn more natural gas
than coal but our friends on the
environmental side hate that because it
still fossil fuels okay so let's forget
about fossil fuels
let's have nuclear energy okay last time
anybody has died from a nuclear accident
was in Chernobyl because the communist
leadership cut corners when it came to
safety and there was a breakdown of
chain of command and whatever and there
wasn't this this accident where where
dozens of people died but since then not
a single person has died as a result of
nuclear accidents including in Fukushima
which is the most recent one so nuclear
energy is a perfect example of producing
a lot of energy without any co2
emissions our our friends in the
environmentalist movement please no they
are not
let's take another example say a
fertilizer let's say that we can
genetically engineer crops to need less
fertilizer and less pesticides why do we
want less fertilizer and less pesticides
because when those flow into rivers and
then into oceans they can have a
negative consequence for wildlife so
ideally you would like to use less
fertilizer less pesticide so imagine
that through GMOs through genetic
engineering we could produce crops that
that that don't require pesticides and
and fertilizer our friends in the
environment will all be happy no they
hate they hate those every single time
that we offer as techno optimists we
offer a gradual move in the right
direction which cumulatively mm-hmm
could have a massive impact on quality
of life on Environmental Protection and
so forth you know the answer is always
no so what so it's interesting because
when when you started talking about this
there's this immediate hesitancy because
I think everyone if you talk about
climate at all people think you're gonna
get slammed and I can tell you the most
hate that I ever got on this show was
when I had Alex Epstein on and wrote a
book called the moral case for fossil
fuels and uh he wasn't denying climate
science he was just saying that fossil
fuels in his estimation are still the
best way to advance human prosperity
going forward so it's interesting you
you immediately said you didn't want to
go too far down that road because it
just opens up the the hate and all that
but but the in essence what you're
saying is that we're having to fight the
environmentalists on what you would
prescribe as the best ways to move the
environment forward but that's pretty
fascinating so how do you get through to
these people then I well I don't know
I'm trying one of the things I'm trying
to explain to a lot of my friends is
that actually prosperity and economic
development can be a friend of the
environment that's because of this
concept of environmental Kuznets curve
now that's just a fancy way of saying
that
when people grow richer they are willing
to spend more money on clean environment
and protection of animals how do I know
that because in in well it's not just
stats which show it but also look at the
real-life examples when the economy
collapsed in Zimbabwe the first thing
the people did in order to survive was
to start slaughtering animals in the
wild shooting zebras for meat shooting
elephants for tusks and and the
environment took a huge knock in
Venezuela when the economy collapsed
both socialist countries by the way but
they never mind in Venezuela when the
economy collapsed
people started slaughtering animals in
the zoo the only way you can survive it
if it's a choice between the life of an
antelope and the survival of a child you
know exactly what to do
and so economic development making
people richer is actually a very good
way of accomplishing this environmental
Kuznets curve when people grow rich they
start caring about the air they breathe
they start caring about welfare of
animals and so on and so forth because
those are from the perspective of the
survival of the human being luxury goods
and we are already seeing some very
interesting things happening around the
world for example the forest coverage of
of the earth is still declining by about
0.08 percent per year but it is
declining primarily if not exclusively
in poor countries and especially in
Africa and also Latin America but it is
increasing in rich countries
afforestation
is taking place there more forests being
grown and in China
we are seeing huge amount of
afforestation because the country is now
richer than what it used to be so
through economic development we can do
that through economic development we can
also we can also start protecting
or our marine life by creating exclusion
zones against fishing and so forth how
can we do that why is that connected to
economic development well because if you
for example you can well not only do you
have more technological ways of
monitoring who is breaking the rules but
also you can still get access to the
food you want through aquaculture mm-hmm
okay
so countries which are richer are able
to are able to get their food from from
aquaculture rather than from from
ordinary shore fishing so when it comes
to these solutions which by the way I
mean what you just said there it's
pretty mind-blowing that in much of the
world it's getting greener you know I
mean that's people just don't think
about that we just sort of just don't
accept that that's real most of this do
you see that we have to have a sort of
public and private partnership on how we
move forward on these things should most
of this come from governments should it
come from private corporations should it
come from individual people I mean that
seems to be what a lot of the debate is
also about well I think that the reefs
that the evidence for the efficacy of
government spending when it comes to
science when it comes to scientific
research for example it's not all that
persuasive I don't think that
governments are particularly good at
spending money on scientific research
meaning that the research is shoddy or
just that they throw money at things and
then just nothing comes of it yeah that
that would be that would be part of
reason I am a believer in in in private
companies doing their own research
driven by the profit motive for example
energy inputs into production of
anything from a can of coke to bottle of
water are cost money
a company's actually do have an
incentive at profit incentive to try to
limit the amount of resources they use
in order to produce any type of good
mm-hm
in the 1970s between 1970s and today the
number of cans of coke that you could
get from a pound of aluminum has
actually increased by something like 40%
that's because companies don't want to
spend money they don't have to spend on
electricity on spending money on Natural
Resources and and and raw materials and
what-have-you and so what we are
actually seeing is that the number of
dollar dollars per what the amount of
the amount of energy we need in order to
produce a dollar of output is actually
declining and that that's happening
naturally through the process of profit
maximization on the parts of
corporations now that doesn't mean that
there is absolutely no need for any kind
of regulations we don't want
corporations to be to be dumping toxic
materials in our pristine rivers and
what have you but but what I am saying
is that is that corporations in search
for profit are actually very good at
coming up with innovative solutions to
environmental problems yeah is part of
the problem here also that different
countries that are at different stages
of their evolution of their economies
and everything else need different
things need wildly different things
what's happening in China now with
growth is very different than what's
happening in the United States or or
India or any of these countries now I
have have two that are often putting out
more co2 and emissions and things like
that they're going through their
industrial or evolutions we already did
it so that we have an unequal playing
field when it comes to some of it yes so
that is a well-known notion within
economic development that as a country
starts on a path to industrialization
its damage to the environment increases
but once again it
is that that inflection point and then
it starts to decrease as people become
rich enough to start to appreciate nice
environment ninety percent of the
plastics that are entering our oceans
come from eight rivers they are all in
the developing world in Africa and in
Asia the contribution of Western
advanced economies to plastic pollution
of the oceans is negligible precisely
because we are able to spend more money
and effort and thought on how not to do
it what would you say to the people that
would say our time is up here or the
evolution of humanity is that we've got
to go to the stars that eventually we'll
have to get off this this mortal coil
and do it again somewhere else well
first of all it is very important to
remember that pessimism about humanity's
future has been with us since the since
the dawn of writing from from antiquity
and ancient poems and epics you know the
the after all the flood what is it about
the flood is about closing the world
rardy depressing population that's that
that went array the K to the elder
writing second century BC thought that
Rome was finished because you know the
the young were corrupted and women had
loose morals and men were too effeminate
to fight wars and this is when Rome was
just a small town in you know with fewer
with a few provinces in Italy Rome
continued to expand for the next three
to four hundred years but he was just
very early he was just very early but
but you can see every generation thinks
that that that we are especially as we
grow older we think that the world is
entering a period of decline whereas in
fact what we are do we are projecting
our own physical decline onto the world
but so far
those those warnings about the imminent
collapse of humanity have always been
proven wrong as thomas babington
macaulay in nineteen century british
politician and writer has written on on
what basis is it that having seen all
this progress that we have made behind
us we see nothing but misery in front of
us
paraphrasing but that's the essence of
what he said and I think he's absolutely
right
yeah so we we've done the diseases were
eradicating we're doing a lot of good on
the environment or at least have have
some options now we do have options yes
yeah what else what else should we be
hitting on to give people some some
positivity to think about well I think
my pet peeve is that I think that people
don't read enough history aren't enough
versed in in in history how life really
used to be like before and I wish that
people would spend more time thinking
about what I'm doing on a daily basis
and asking themselves would I be able to
do this in the past
mm-hm I just had a crown of put in or a
root canal operation with anesthetic and
it was it was not something and it
wasn't a particularly pleasant right but
but but it was better than it would have
been 100 years ago 100 or 200 years ago
you're not having you know somebody
would have to pull it out of your out of
your mouth and so that's one thing I
think that people and I think that if
people understand history better and how
life truly was quite horrific until very
recent times again we have three hundred
thousand years old but but the time of
abundance is roughly two hundred years
old two hundred fifty years old maybe
they will be more grateful and for the
things that we have and hopefully they
will be more appreciative and more
supporting of the institutions which
underpin modernity liberal democracy
with all of its warts with all of its
imperfection
it is still functioning better than
Putin's Russia or or arrogance Turkey
free-market capitalism does it have its
problems yes
we shouldn't socialize costs of banking
for example and privatized and
privatized gains from Wall Street
banking but again it is the best it is
the best creator of wealth known to
humankind and so throwing it out because
there are imperfections on the margins
that we should be working on to improve
would be a great mistake
so yes appreciation of the past
gratitude for the present hopefulness
for the future those are the steps in I
think in the right direction that my
friend is an A+ ending to an interview
and for more on Marion and the
incredible work that Think Progress is
doing you guys can check out
thinkprogress.org
[Music]